hello hello hello hello hello everyone hello lieutenant
spicy uh uh skull hello major michael spark holy shit who am
i missing am i missing anyone else michael hello everyone
we're gonna got you out all right um it's time it's time to
play the spooky game uh just until the barely visible okay
maybe I should just make it extra bright maybe I just hey TV
hey hey sneaking on them all right maybe I should just make
it extra bright so I can't be spooked I'm scared I'm
actually who I heard it's not that scary I heard it's just
um I heard I heard that like is not as scary as I as as like
all the other games so that's why I chose this that's why i
chose this game because i heard it's not as not as scary
yeah because it's just all like atmospheric i have no idea
what this game is about i all i know is that they're on a
ship that's all i know about this game um but yeah i've
never i've never heard played this before little nightmares
is so good i heard it's really good i heard there are two
mouse cursors oh no where's the other one oh i see i see i
see okay i have to pull all right i know how to fix this but
um does it really bother you guys okay i'm gonna fix it is
gonna be a weird fix chat i'll fix it real quick for the for
the mouse cursor um um let me chat i'm just gonna fix the
It's to deal with my lepit.
It's to deal with my program, so I'm gonna fix it technical
difficulties I know I know we're always having technical
difficulties here Um, so I didn't choose outlast.
Yeah, I didn't want to play outlast because I heard I it's
really spooky and I've only played like I've played like
three spooky games in my like two spooky games in my life
and I'd rather not play I'd rather not play out last guy.
I'd rather go in go in with the less spooky game for it's I
don't want to go in right into into like the most spooky one
um I have to I have to fix it I'm because of the the mouse
thingy it has to do with my lupin I have to like put it on
the other side and stuff so so um this is gonna it's just me
doing technical stuff real quick uh where's my where is oh
my god i'm so tiny now holy i'm so tiny let me fix this chat
i was it like this i don't even remember how well looking
was it the size oh i don't remember i don't is this okay is
this okay uh bigger is this all right better i don't
remember i already forgot what it was supposed to look like
was it like this is better all right all right all right
take up the whole screen okay okay like this right ah there
you go perfect that's perfect right
oh yeah this is very very spooky very you remove the rain in
my face all right i forgot was it like this size before also
love you thank you so much for the vibe it's thank you thank
you so much um but yeah is the size of is the size of a
model like this okay chat this is okay or do you want me to
um um is this okay okay because i don't remember how it used
to look like i already forgot so um i think this is fine um
all right all right all right let's let's pull up this is
not what i wanted whoops technical difficulties again
Alright, let's go, let's go.
Embers, thank you so much!
Embers, thank you!
Thank you for the tier one sub for five.
Let's get some bark nights real quick for Embers.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Also, thank you so much for the 41 bits, Lieutenant.
Thank you.
Alright, let's start this game.
the set bible pump one bible pump one bible pump one bible
all right keyboard all right grab crouch slide blighter all
right let's go in let's go in and play this game let's start
it let's start it as is all right good night spicy thanks
for stopping by good night good night well we have good
night to rest for school all right let's okay okay i'm
mentally preparing myself i I hear it's not that spooky so
so let's pray I won't like fuck up.
I heard it's also a puzzle game too so thanks chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for making me use my brain yet again.
Of course you guys would make me use my brain in the spooky
game.
I ain't even see you shake my head.
I'm more scared I'll just swap these puzzles.
Our brain.
True, true.
We'll use our brain together.
What the fuck is this girl?
Who are you?
Okay, you'll use your brain more in Vizage.
Don't worry.
Oh my god.
I'll donate my brain cells all of it.
Thank you for your kind donations, chat.
Can I move?
Oh, I can move.
Oh, there's a lighter.
is there your timer on this oh i can fix it up oh look at
that look at that i can't hold on to it can i bring my cam
with me oh shit is this a puzzle oh my god am i gonna oh i
know i see i see i I'm building something here, right?
Okay, no, that wasn't it.
Hey, crush.
Alright, I'm just gonna bring this with me.
Shit, I can't see shit.
Alright, who gives a fuck?
Wait, oh, I thought I could pick this up and use the
lighter.
Okay, alright.
Alright, hey, movie!
I can't wait right now because I'm picking shit up.
Can I...
What's this?
Oh, can I like this?
oh my god i'm so smart i maybe go a little bit smaller oh
you want me my model to be a bit smaller
you guys want my model to be smaller chat what are you here
no
just a little bit okay okay let me fix it real quick guys
for you guys uh just a little bit i'll just also move it
over here a little bit more All right, let me zoom.
All right, what the fuck do I do?
Oh, oh, push, pull, push, pull.
Okay, maybe I need to get my cat out of the way.
Okay, push, oh, pull.
All right, come with me.
Come with me.
Wait, can I not bring it?
Oh my god, this is too...
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, let me in.
Let me...
Let me in!
Please!
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I have to crouch.
Okay.
I'll just kick it.
I'll just kick the can.
Okay, never mind.
Fuck you.
I don't need the can.
I don't...
I don't need the can anyway.
What?
Oh, I climb!
Rip the can.
I don't need you.
Can I look up?
Oh, what's this?
What's this?
Wait, can I jump off here?
What happens if I...
Oh, oh, wait, you can!
I thought that would be an invisible wall!
Well...
Look, I thought, I thought, you know, there was an invisible
wall, you know.
like here it was all just a dream you see her wake up it was
just a dream chat
stupid you guys think of the fact that oh it's just oh poor
oh it's like the but can i oh i can jump wait who's that
who's that i could jump oh
my oh okay no no i'm sorry i'm sorry i didn't know I didn't
know!
I'm sorry!
Can I push this?
Okay, no.
Wait, what?
What the fuck was that?
Wait, what the fuck?
Here's Neil.
Why is everything so tiny?
The poor side- You're gonna die now!
Tell me so bad things!
No!
Oh, toilet paper.
Hey.
Die here?
Oh no, there's a vault here.
I feel like I have toilet paper.
Alright, I want to read this.
Pick up the note.
Oh my god.
I don't know what I can- Oh, can I pick up the shoe?
I can pick- I can pick up the shoe!
I can pick up the shoe!
Oh shit, wait, I need to get in there.
This is- they take place in a 20- go for like five thousand
dollars wait oh that's a body oh shit dude i thought it was
just decoration i thought it was just a long light honestly
i mean what's that you know i have my priority street i was
like look at the shoe and apparently there was there was a
body above me clearly the shoe was a lot more important
He was the long boy.
Wait.
I'm not spooked yet.
This is just a long walking simulator where I pick up shoes.
The shoe, yeah, the shoes are more important than every...
Oh, can I open this fridge?
Oh!
Oh.
Oh, there's just...
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, shit!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
wait come on yeah come on oh there's more shoes can i pick
up the shoe oh i won't let me pick up the shoe so it's
basically dead standing how do i how do i climb up bonnet's
toilet
it's just so long lieutenant thank you so much for the
father maple's knife thank you so much like for the for the
gifts itself thank you to get some bark nights real quick
for for lieutenant for the get the sub oh then more like
little shoes exactly oh wait what the fuck i was gonna pick
it up i was like oh shit i can pick it up
where the fuck is that okay now now i know it's dangerous
it's a dangerous boy yeah that's right That's true.
What are you gonna do?
Follow me?
Yeah.
Come on.
You can't catch me.
Yeah.
What are you gonna do, huh?
Huh?
What are you gonna do?
Yeah?
Yeah.
It's gonna kill me one day.
I'm gonna, um, I'm gonna leave.
Oh,
is that another one?
Oh, that's another.
Oh, that's more.
Oh, there's too many.
Oh, they're all following me.
Joke's on you guys.
I live.
Is that a shoe?
Oh, wait.
They're following me.
You're not dropping?
Okay.
Oh, there you don't drop.
Oh!
Let me...
Oh.
But it doesn't do shit.
Okay, I was gonna be like...
What are you gonna do?
Kill me?
Pull?
Climb?
Oh, pull!
What the fuck is that?
Whoa!
Okay!
where am i what oh oh i start here okay oh no wait no no get
away
wait how do i get out of here how do i get push push push
push
okay i hear this game is like two to three hours long so i'm
gonna finish it in an hour.
I bet there was spring for anything.
That's so nasty, right?
Oh, the self-goal!
Oh, I forgot to swap it!
Oh, what are you?
What are you?
I forgot I was supposed to say 400 instead of 3.
I forgot to change it.
How do I climb?
How the fuck do I have to climb?
Please.
Oh, you hold on to it.
Okay.
Ken's
What?
What do I do?
Oh.
Apparently I can't climb.
The mug used to climb in chat.
Okay.
Okay, I was gonna be like, where's the lights?
What the fuck?
There's a fall damage here!
There's a fall damage!
What?
Why the fuck is there fall damage?
Oh, wait!
Topic, no, no, no.
Dying to save time on the run.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can't know there's fall damage.
Okay, look, I have a bed.
Okay, please don't touch me.
Please do not touch me.
I had fall.
Oh, wait.
Whoa.
Okay, how the fuck was I supposed to know there was fall
damage here?
Okay, I gotta get past this checkpoint, so I don't have to
do that again.
Also, is the sound okay for you guys?
The sound of the game?
Because I- Oh, oh my god, what the fuck!
I forgot about that.
Because I don't know if you guys can hear the game sound.
Because it's, like, very atmospheric.
Okay.
Wait, where do I go then?
Oh, do I jump?
I jump, right?
I jump.
That gnome is actually moving.
Okay.
Push.
Hey, Bippy!
Oh, oh, oh!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
I run and then I run and then I run can I sprint oh wait you
can sprint why did no one tell me I can sprint here I've
been fucking walking this entire time you can sprint in this
game hey oh yeah yeah yeah you can sprint yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah come on come on come on how the how the fun
Wait, do I jump here?
What do I get to die from fall damage again?
Okay, okay.
Okay, by the way, there's fall damage.
Okay, okay, okay, let me see.
All right, okay.
Oh, now it tells me!
Now the game tells me that I can sprint!
Oh, thank you!
Thank you!
Now it tells me!
Okay.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
Oh my god, dude, I'm so fucking good at jumping.
I told you that the last two times.
I didn't...
I didn't see.
Oh!
What the fuck?
Oh, it just lets out the gnome out.
Where does it take me?
Wait.
Is there a point going up?
Oh, no.
There's no reason for me to climb.
Why not?
Oh, you're a little green and I'm just screaming.
Whoa, that gnome is fast.
Okay.
I'm so fucking good at jumping.
Exactly.
Oh, what's that?
Oh, oh, okay, guys.
That chocolate made them!
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a have a but heart.
Thank you so much.
Oh, shit.
Do I get seven feet tall?
IRL?
Wait, wait, what?
Let me in.
What?
No, no, please!
What the fuck?
I don't...
Oh damn it.
Oh, good.
Look.
Thank you for the world record.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't believe we've only been playing this game for like
10 minutes.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck is that?
Hey, my curious.
Okay.
Okay, how do I...
How do I...
Let me in.
The fuck you want... Oh, okay.
I don't know how the fuck I got in.
I don't know.
I don't know how I got in there.
Boom.
Let me in.
Oh, look at this racks.
There's toilet paper.
Can I take these toilet paper out?
Oh, I can't.
Put it in the paper.
Put in the paper.
Oh.
Okay.
All right.
That's bad.
electricity bad electricity bad so what's supposed to be I
don't know apparently it's like atmospherically scary but oh
wait give me light light light
eat the right hand apparently it's a good game though but I
don't know what's scary about it it's just puzzles it's just
like a spooky puzzle game but it's gonna it's the first
scary game so we're going we're starting it we're just
starting it with a timid game i don't know if it'll ever be
really scary because we just make the mood so much later i
don't mean to it's just i don't know i'm just too stupid to
make it seem scary like why is it here so tiny look around
by using wow by using arrow keys Oh, shit.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I'm like, oh, shit.
I'm looking.
I'm looking respectfully.
How do I get up, though?
I mean, I looked.
I looked.
What do you want me to do afterwards?
I'm looking.
What do you do?
Oh, there's something behind me.
this oh
that's what I need the toilet paper for toilet paper just
jump did you know you can look around okay hmm like bad wait
there's a timer wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait Wait, let me through, let me through.
Okay.
Don't.
There's bloody handprints on that dresser.
Oh, there is.
Look, there are my hands.
Wait, wait.
I can pull.
Oh, I can't.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I can pull.
I, I, I, no, stop picking.
up i can pull oh oh i can't i can't walk though okay
okay what do i do here
okay oh oh oh okay what am i supposed to do do i die by do
this okay no i won't You're gonna, like, you've been on a
bench.
I don't know what to do here.
Oh.
I'm just peek- Hey, look.
Smoking.
I can pull.
Pull.
Oh, come on.
You can pull.
Oh.
Ah.
Okay, maybe not that.
Does this hurt me?
Oh, this hurts me.
This hurts me.
does this hurt me oh oh my god this should not be oh hey
fuck you stupid train
oh i can look all right there's nothing up there up up okay
not up
okay the fuck
okay what do i do up here what is this I'm looking
respectfully I'm looking respectfully oh oh oh I just
speedrun I have the speedrun okay okay okay okay don't worry
I'm the best at speedrunning I just alright alright look at
this bam I'm fucking running I'm is this fuck I'm fucking
please please stop thinking I'm the best oh my god tripping
over everything I'm fast though look at that I'm so oh god
please stop tripping holy I'm so I'm zooming I'm zoomer oh
my gosh look at that I could have died haha I'm a zoomer I
was born in 2010 I I think wait what's that?
What?
The fuck?
Is that water?
Well, how old would I be when I was born in 2000?
I'll be like 10 years old.
Wait.
Yeah, I'll be 10 years old.
What's that?
What's that with seal?
Boom.
I don't know what's the point of all these.
Oh, not TOs.
Okay, sorry.
I'm born at 2007 so that would make me that would make me 13
so I won't get banned okay I wait I realize I should not
what the fuck is that I wish I shouldn't say that you could
clip that out of context and Twitch will actually think I'm
13 or like 10 I am legal age to be streaming on Twitch
what's that what is that oh no no no no no no no you can't
see me because I have this thing
yeah that's right oh it's nine
i can pass i'm fast oh jane i'm fast i'm fast i'm fast this
fuck i'm fast this fuck i'm fast this fuck i'm fast this
fuck those dead kids i'll be dead
i'm fast this fuck i'm fast this fuck i'm fast this fuck
okay i want to light this this
won't hurt me yeah i can't find me stupid boom i don't know
that that does but i just want it you're really a zoomer you
were born before 2010.
what's that is that a little gnome what are you doing there
i'm gonna oh Oh, wait, do I pull?
No, no pulling.
Do I climb?
Oh, I climb.
Climb.
Should I free that guy?
I'm going to free him.
No, you know what?
Fuck it.
I'm not here to do achievements.
Fuck you.
I don't care about achievements.
No.
No one cares about him.
Look, hence.
This is my bed?
No, that doesn't matter.
Did I jump?
Jump.
That must be an achievement somewhere.
Hide?
Do I need to hide something?
Oh!
Wait, wait, is this another statue I can throw?
oh it is it's our
oh I jump right I look wait okay no I don't jump there's
nothing there is it actually bad to destroy those statues I
don't know if I can you know push where do I go
let's see I think it's just achievement stuff.
I don't care about achievements.
I'm just here to get a speedrun.
I'm going to finish this game in an hour, chat.
I can't believe I've only been playing for like 10 minutes
already.
Do you know that the humming noises slowly get faster?
What humming noises?
What?
Ah!
Who are you?
Don't check out the other bed.
Don't check out the bed.
Don't drink under a bed!
Bye.
Wait, wait, where do I go?
Wait, where do I go?
Where do I go?
Oh, let me hit.
Let me hit.
Up.
Where do I go?
He doesn't know He doesn't know He doesn't know He doesn't
know I don't know where to go
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay Oh, push, pull, pull Wait,
there has to be an entrance here Ready?
Push, no, no, no Pull, pull, wait, no, no, up?
Up?
Let me What the fuck?
Where do I go?
Oh, oh, wait, how do I push you?
How do I push you?
Oh, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up here.
It's up here.
I'm so good at this game.
All right.
Just.
She's reading it out.
Okay, okay.
I'm safe, I'm safe.
Down?
No.
Oh, I'm hungry.
I'm hungry.
Me too, man.
I'll pick this up.
Okay, I need food.
Can I surprise y'all with brain cells after you took him
off?
Is there like a, uh, is there like a time, like, timer
because of how hungry I am?
Or can I just...
Hey there, kid.
Give me your food.
Hello.
Hey.
Give me your food.
Yeah, it's me.
Hey.
Oh, you gave me food!
Yeah, that's race sim.
Okay.
What a fucking simp.
Yeah, that's right.
I ate your food.
That's right.
Is he gonna stare at me?
What a freak.
Oh, he's crying!
Yell a little bitch!
Yell you a little bitch.
Wait, where'd I go?
No, he's just lying.
Oh, shit.
I wonder if that little kid shows up again.
Dude, I'm zooming.
Now you guys said this is...
What are you doing with this?
Now you guys said this is scary.
I killed you for eating.
use food oh okay so i don't need i don't need this oh can i
push this off
shit where do i go oh uh
can i go all right why are you open open up oh what if you
eat your food next time then it'd be a horror game I
actually thought I was gonna fuck that up.
Okay, okay.
Oh, let's get- Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, okay, wait, wait.
Oh,
did I just keep going up?
Okay, I would die if I jump off from there.
I would die if I do that.
This is fine.
Yeah.
Oh,
I guess I...
God, please don't.
Please, please, please.
How do I...
How...
Oh, here?
Yeah.
So what the fuck was the ladder for?
What the fuck?
What was this ladder for if I could just use that?
Oh, oh, thank you so much for the follow!
Cold Railgun, thank you.
Thank you.
I do appreciate it.
Have a butthart.
Thank you so much.
What the fuck was that for?
Excuse me?
Please.
What?
And then push?
Oh.
Huh?
What?
Oh, please don't need...
What is this for?
What are you for?
What are
we going to trigger?
What's trigger of COVID?
Don't die.
Oh!
Oh shit, wait.
Oh.
Wait, then how do I turn this lever?
Wait, what?
Oh, hey.
And how do I turn this?
I am.
I'm so confused.
I do this, and then I run.
I run.
Oh, I run.
Oh, I'm so fucking smart.
I didn't know.
Here.
I'm doing a little nightmare so far.
I think, like, I thought it was spooky.
But, but it wasn't as spooky as I thought.
It was just atmospheric.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much.
Look at that!
Marshall!
Thank you so much for the tier one six months.
Woo!
Can we get some bark night material quick for Marshall?
Thank you.
be like more spooky than i than originally thought but but
at the moment i'm not i'm not spooked at the moment oh oh
yeah that's right but this is the first this was this is the
this is the first spooky game so we'll gradually get
spookier each each uh each stream each variety stream okay
let me let me up and then oh oh okay not like that okay not
like that okay not this no
i'm not gonna play alas i i'm oh my hand what the fuck i
didn't even notice it it's just a tracker it was just a
tracker bugging him no i do i do have my hand here my
tracker's bugging up i'm sorry
Okay, alright, is this another speedy run?
Would you play Alien?
I don't know, I don't know.
I think I'm gonna play Visage after the next stream.
Visage is scary, right?
I want to gradually get scarier.
What's this?
Oh!
Oh, that's the news.
Is Visage scary, chat?
Oh, who are you?
bitch.
Alright, we're gonna play Massage next stream.
Because I wanted to gradually get spookier each game.
But, like, I'm going into each game blind, so I don't know
what the fuck is going on.
Like, I don't know what the fuck is.
I don't know what the story is.
I just know I'm a little girl.
I'm just a little girl.
That's all.
Oh!
I'm a little tiny girl.
looking running around at a ship and I I'm hungry like like
oh what are oh get away I can run I am
a little girl in the in the yellow raincoat that's all that
matters in life what oh I just need to go through here why
am I climbing I am an alien why am I climbing
Oh, oh, oh, oh, here we go again.
Here we go again.
It's okay.
Oh, no!
Wait!
I thought that hit me.
Okay.
All right.
Okay, okay, okay.
I can zoom.
All right.
Puzzle time.
Zoom.
Oh shit, I can slide.
Yeah what you gonna do, huh?
Oh, no!
No no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no!
No no no no no!
No!
That was the vows with them.
I was the vows.
I didn't zoom hard enough.
Here.
What you gonna do, huh?
That's right.
this is like oh so she's like to be up past bedtime as a kid
you're gonna do a thing where like um um you're you're
reading a book or something like back then when you don't
have like iPhones or whatever and then your mom comes in or
your dad comes in and you like fucking hide your hide your
book or your game boy underneath your covers and pretend to
sleep I did that one.
Is there bunny hopping here?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm bee hopping.
Wait.
Wait, I think...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, I'm so
good.
the scariest moment when you realized you knew they were
awake yeah you could hear their footsteps outside your room
and then you're like oh fuck and then you like hide here
you're like whatever you're like looking at underneath your
covers or under your pillow and then and then close your
eyes as they went come into your bedroom hey hey no toxicity
I'm not spooked at all I'm just vibing I'm just bee hopping
not spooked oh I thought that was where the staircase was.
Okay, anyway, I'm not sweet at all.
I'm just be on me.
Did you even fall?
Look, I thought that was where the staircase was.
Can you go here?
Oh, hey there.
I like this.
I like you.
Oh They open you Do you learn different footsteps like I
know my mom's footsteps patterns and my dad's Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, I did that like I would know if it was my mom or
dad coming into my room What Doesn't take me shit what wait
wait, why can't I go through?
Let me through What are you?
What?
Oh, I need to push.
I need to push?
What?
Is...
Am I supposed to go through here?
Push?
Oh, fuck this.
I don't care.
Okay, I guess we don't go this way.
What?
What was that?
What's that sound?
What?
What is that?
What is
that?
What the fuck is that?
Hey, Juki.
It goes through now?
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
Come on!
Okay.
Are you gonna open again?
Are you gonna open?
It's closed.
what you guys heard that right i'm so confused well i think
i can go up here i'm pretty sure there's i can also go up
here okay i don't know what the fuck that room was that was
that was spooky though can i open this no
there's a pressure plate i don't know i don't what the fuck
that was.
Like, also thank you so much for the follow, Ravioli.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a, have a butthard.
Thank you so much.
Wait, really?
Okay, let me check.
Let me look at it again.
Let me look at it.
Let me, let me see that again.
I'm, I was curious.
That, that spooked me.
I bet you that's what they do to speed run this.
They do little bunny hops like this.
No, there's no pressure plate here though.
Oh!
Oh, there is!
You're so smart!
Holy shit, look at...
Wait, what the fuck do we do upstairs?
There it is!
But, what about upstairs, though?
I don't know where to go.
Do we go up or here, chat?
Which one should we try?
Okay, let me bring this light down with me.
Should we go up or right here?
Okay, let me bring you with me.
enough okay
okay hey what is this taking Biden hey what's this stupid oh
oh no what is this oh I remember this I know this guy I've
seen this guy before and like But other people were playing
this game.
I remember seeing the creepy chef.
This is all here before.
Oh, who are you?
I'm not learning nothing.
I think this is for like plot and stuff.
But I'm not really learning anything.
Is that it?
Oh, is this plot?
Oh shit, this is plot.
So, like, wait, what the fuck?
That's new.
What's this?
Plot.
Wait, what?
What?
What are you?
What the fuck are you?
Okay, bye.
I guess I was learning plot the entire time.
I...
I have no idea what I learned today.
Hey.
Oh, no!
No!
Fuck!
I'm back here!
I didn't...
Is that a little thing there?
Do I have to do plot again?
I'll give stuff to you, but I've not followed, so.
Photoshop, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Have a bloodhark.
Thank you.
I have no idea what I learned today.
Also, doubles.
Devils, doubles.
Ah, whatever.
I'm clicking not.
Okay.
Thank you so much for your follow.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
also have a have a blood heart.
Okay, do you have to do plot again?
Plot.
I don't know if it's like a thing that I have to, you know
what, we'll do plot again.
Let's go.
We usually have some portal, right?
All right, plot time.
I don't know if it like keeps it.
Does it keep it?
Oh, no, it doesn't.
Okay, okay.
Speed run plot.
speed ramps we're speed running please let me keep pressing
I was like hey Jackie son alright I'm gonna walk alright
done we sped run plot we've learned we've learned about her
past and where she came from
okay time to go back up have I learned from my mistakes not
really.
I have not really learned.
Oh my god, you can't see that?
Wait, wait, let me do that again.
Oh god.
This is supposed to be a spooky game.
Boom.
Oh, can I open this?
No.
This girl has mad endurance, right?
See, she's, like, strong as fuck, apparently.
Like, look at that.
What do I do with you?
Push?
Okay, not, not like that.
Oh!
Chew.
Oh, I should push this over there.
Okay.
because this is a bit slow.
Is that a dog?
Holy shit, that's an like, what the fuck?
Wait, is that?
Is that?
Does he have a freaking dick as a nose?
Chat, you see that, right?
Like, what?
You guys see?
Oh, wait, no.
That's not a dog.
Wait, that's not a dog.
I thought I was...
I thought I was a dog.
I just had to look closer.
I don't know what the fuck that was.
But his nose was a big peepee on Angie right there.
Is it timed?
What are you speaking?
Does this mean the complete opposite for me?
Okay.
Where did I go?
Here?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
That was not where I go.
Oh, I have to push it again.
No!
Why couldn't they just give me the suitcase where it was?
I wonder how far we are already in this game.
Because it's supposed to be a two to three hour game.
And I'm already- I've already played this game for ten
minutes.
Why is it so spooky?
What's the spooky noise for?
Okay, clearly the light has no meaning.
Oh, shit!
Who you?
Who you, mister?
He doesn't have hair, and he's wearing a hat.
You know what I say?
We don't need hair.
Just wear a hat.
He's okay.
He looks okay.
What the fuck is this on ice?
Oh!
Oh, no, no, no, no!
I'm gonna turn you on?
Hey.
Okay, I guess I do that again?
Because I fucked up?
True, I'm probably almost done.
Oh, there's a key.
There's a key down there!
I didn't see the key.
I didn't use the key then.
Okay, key.
Key.
Bye.
Okay, I thought I died there.
Okay, where do I use you?
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Where do I- do I know?
Where the fuck do I use this key?
uh
that up am i not supposed to eat this wait what do you do
with you
uh suitcase no okay i don't know what to do with you
key uh key
key key key key uh okay help okay i feel like this key i
feel like this key there was nothing to do with this key i
just i just brought it down for no reason okay I go back
you'll figure it out I'm figuring it out she's learning
though so it's a steady process what do I do with the key
where is the lock okay wait if I look up no no no I'm
looking boom okay I go up here hey Hey, oh, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, where is the key?
Wait,
okay, okay, maybe here.
Oh, you can climb up this.
Oh, oh, is that a dead guy?
What the fuck is that?
What are you?
Oh, it's just pants.
It's just pants.
It's just his pants.
What do I do here?
Oh, I'm alive.
Oh.
Where's Key?
Where Key go?
Oh, my God!
Can I push this?
Oh, why did you sell me?
Oh!
Oh, I fucking cry.
Ah!
Thank you, V.
All right, time to get key again.
I can't know.
I'm like, oh, is that a holder?
Okay.
All right, time to go back down.
Bam, speeder in.
Bam.
Key.
Throw.
Boom!
Oh my god, she was going up!
Alright, give me the key.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, excuse me.
I'm baby.
Here we go.
Look at that speedrun chat.
Look at that.
It's not like it's not like I died or anything.
Hey, Eddie.
Yeah, I don't need you.
Stupid key.
Oh.
I'm so fast.
What do you do?
Huh?
Why?
Do I chuck you?
Uh.
Oh.
Okay.
Wait, can I just push this open?
No.
What the fuck do I...
Carrying an object?
get cold yeah I did what the fuck you we what uh what
checking okay okay okay okay
come on oh my god now it works I don't know I don't even
know how far we are members I don't know are Are we pretty
far in this game?
Please tell me we're pretty far.
Please don't tell me we're only 20% done with this game.
There's no way.
There's no way there's more to it.
I don't know.
We're still in the dark.
I'm there.
Yeah, I've never played this.
I don't fucking know.
Can I push you?
Uh-huh.
No?
Pull?
No.
I'm in a box.
We passed Longboy from the, um, in the baby thingy, in the
baby thing.
Like a bunch of babies and we passed him.
What the fuck?
Did I bring you back?
All right, where are you?
I'm bringing you back.
I don't fucking know what we're doing with you I don't know
Do something He's not doing anything So I don't know anymore
I don't know
I'm climbing What do you want me to do What do you Is it me
or the light getting brighter what the fuck
i'm just stuck here oh oh oh oh okay no wait no no okay
please okay i'm just bad at aiming i guess i'm just i'm just
bad at aim
Did he bring you?
I'm so smart.
Hey.
Okay, are you hungry again?
Oh, you're a little bit.
Alright, don't worry.
We'll get you food.
Okay, don't worry, I'm gonna get you food.
Don't worry, please just keep jumping.
Oh, no, please, please.
I'm gonna get you food.
Please, just walk for...
Oh, I can't jump anymore.
I'm too hungry.
Hey, Metal.
Oh, shit.
Is that me?
Oh, God.
That's disgusting.
Oh, oh, my God.
What the fuck is wrong?
Your hands.
Love me.
Thank you so much.
We're going to find this.
Thank you.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
What is he?
What is he doing?
Let me out.
Oh.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
That's looking right.
I'm leaving.
Bye.
Yeah, I don't give a fuck about the little other people
trapped there.
To each their own.
I just go out here?
Oh, okay.
I do not go there.
I think...
Okay, we learned that I do not, oh my god, you're gonna make
me watch this, I'm sorry, it's gonna make me watch this
cutscene again, I'm sorry.
I won't do it again.
Okay, all right, all right.
Okay, well, now I know.
Now I know.
Okay, I know we go through here, right?
Okay, what the fuck do we do now?
Oh, thank you so much for the follow, as a flower as a
flower as I'm so sorry.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I love, have a but heart.
Thank you so much.
Okay, what do we do here?
Is there a way?
Uh-huh.
Okay.
okay i don't want to jump off again i don't want to jump off
again go back inside oh do i a little bitch yeah oh i use
you i use you for my own gain i see i see yeah cry okay so
there was like no point in going what other than achievement
shit okay oh
let me climb up let me i don't i don't care about you let me
climb up i let me oh i don't i don't care just let me let me
let me climb let me oh there you go
Please, please, please, I don't care!
I don't care!
Tidu, thank you so much for the 29 bits!
Come on, please, please!
I'm sorry.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much for the 29 bits.
Okay.
Okay, let me push you.
Okay, I am very bad at directional shit.
I don't know where the fuck this is.
Oh.
Here we go.
Alright.
Oh, I need to keep holding.
I need to keep holding.
Okay.
And then I'm going to swing.
And I'm going to swing.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I got this.
Boom.
Boom, boom, boom, boom!
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah, that's three I mean so good Where do I go I need it
Push Come on, come on What the fuck?
Oh Wait, wait is that a thing here?
Oh, that's not that I thought that was Wait, wait, wait,
wait, here?
No.
What the fuck do I do?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Maybe.
Okay.
If all else fell, just keep going up.
Just keep climbing.
Oh, shit.
Is this a guillotine?
Why the fuck is there a guillotine here?
Come on.
Let me in.
Boom.
We caught in.
What about your new bodies?
What is he gonna do?
Oh, oh, no, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh, you a bit!
Yeah, you're so stupid!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, I don't know where to go!
I don't know where to go!
Wait!
No!
I'm sorry!
I don't want to do it after that.
Oh, okay.
No, you're gonna fucking do- Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Please, please, please.
Please.
No!
What the?
I keep forgetting
X, I can't do it for the 31 bits.
For the 31 bits.
Thank you, thank you.
XS MLA, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
I also have heart.
Thank you so much.
I got this.
First try.
Please, please leave.
What?
Please just leave.
Okay.
Okay, first try.
Let me try.
All right.
Anyway, that was just a dream.
That was just a dream.
This is the try.
If I keep doing it, I'll succeed.
Oh, I just gonna keep doing it.
I just, I just need to keep running.
Please, no!
How do I get this?
How?
Where are you?
Do I need shoe?
Shoe.
No.
Do I need a thump one Bible thump one Bible thump one Bible.
so much on the butt oh this this i don't need shoe i didn't
need shoe i didn't need shoe thank you so much for the bits
you didn't know i'm so fucking smart first try first try
Oh my god.
Let's first try chat.
Dude, stop giving me shoes.
Shoes.
What should I bring you?
I got it for nourishing me with spit.
I need hydrate.
I need looking hydrate after that.
Hmm.
Okay.
Got this.
Look at that.
try we didn't die at all I'm we're scared don't you scream
what you mean I never screamed in my life what the fuck are
all these shoes there's so many shoes look at all these
shoes wait I can't even jump there's just too many oh oh
what are you what are you let me up let me up oh my god wait
okay let me look let me look
okay oh please please please please let me out let me out no
no hey lady let me out I gotta get out Oh my god There's so
many So many shoes Please No Please Yeah that's right That's
right Yeah That's what you're gonna do Huh?
What do you like?
go though hello fuck oh shit we're 75% holy shit okay all
right okay I got this I'm sprinting please please please
please please please no no no no yeah that's right you
little bitch yeah you little bitch what you gonna do huh I
thought it was gonna fall off.
I honestly thought.
What do I want?
What do you can't do with me?
Oh!
I was like, what the fuck?
Please!
No!
Oh!
Why?
I was through!
I got through!
What?
It was cheeky.
I had to do it again!
Okay, I know what's going to happen this time.
Yeah, slide.
I'm sliding.
You can't get me this time!
Please!
Yeah!
You can't get me!
Wait, wait, wait, how do I do?
Wait, I don't have anything to close this!
Wait!
Please, he doesn't know!
He doesn't know!
He doesn't!
Wait, did he got me?
Did he got me?
Oh he- Oh, he didn't!
Ha!
I wanted to think I was scared of and you made it come
chewed, darn it.
Okay, okay, we got this again.
We got...
Okay, okay, God.
Yo.
Boom, it can't get me.
I'm fast as fuck, boy.
That's right, you can't scare me again.
You can't scare me.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please,
please, please, please, please, don't touch me.
I know, I know what to do.
I know what to do now.
I know.
Oh, yeah, I'm in the box.
Can't get me.
I'm in a box.
I'm sorry.
Ow.
Look at that stupid.
Just seen it.
Can't see me.
It's stupid.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Yes, Ray.
Put that down.
gnome that's right i'm safe
oh what did i join into what the fuck is that snake battle
this
i think we have like a eclipse channel i'm pretty sure we
have a eclipse channel here okay yeah we didn't have mine
do we need to throw this again Oh
What the fuck Oh my god Dylan Thank you so much
Dylan thank you so much for the tier one seven months Can we
get some break nights real quick for Dylan Thank you thank
you thank you Uh how goes the stream so hard dude we're
fucking speedrunning it We've only been playing this game
for like 20 minutes and we're almost done I have no idea
what I'm doing right now.
I'm just pushing this box
Yeah, I haven't I haven't died once or or screamed at all
Wait, do I just push this Push real
What what do you do?
What?
What the fuck?
gonna see 11 man push win probably as well on that one slide
oh shit here jump no
all right all right I'm trying to figure this shit out I'm
using my brain here my green is expanding it has to be down
It is down!
How do I get in you?
Oh!
We sent a screenshot on your disc screen, and I blame you
for...
For... for reading Dust Toss Teal.
What do I do?
Get down!
Oh!
I'm so smart.
Oh, here we go.
Oh shit, look at that.
What is he doing?
What are you doing?
Crazy Lemon Man!
Thank you so much for the follow!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a butthart.
Thank you so much.
What does she do with the bristles, right?
Can I just leave?
I don't want to go.
Stupid.
Oh, he's so creepy.
See?
Okay, I'm going to fucking spoon it's gonna leave I leave oh
look there's a dog oh
is he gone oh he's gone what the do I do okay we're down a
few months basically flipping for a long last time and says
you know what I'll finish downloading now okay What the fuck
is that?
It looks like a Frege Cougar's blind cousin.
He doesn't have hair.
He wears a hat because he's bald.
Does he just want me to climb up?
I'm not climbing up.
Dude, what the fuck?
Am I supposed to wait?
I don't fuck it.
What's he gonna do?
Kill me?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
I heard that I was like, I'm going back down.
Wait, he doesn't...
Wait, wait, where am I supposed to go?
Okay, okay, we're gonna...
We're gonna let him kill me.
Kill me first.
Because I have no idea...
What did I just do?
Yeah, come back here!
Stupid!
Okay.
I'm supposed to sneak.
Just go.
Sneak, stupid.
Oh!
He just...
Just...
Stupid.
What?
No!
You're not stupid!
I'm sorry.
What the fuck is that?
We're calling you stupid.
I don't know where to go.
Oh, he doesn't know.
He doesn't know.
Okay, maybe he knows.
Where do I go?
I know she didn't.
He might know.
There's nothing else to say about it.
I'm trying to figure out where to go.
I don't know where to go after.
Where the fuck do I go?
go what the fuck i
accidentally called him stupid now he's mad okay okay where
do i go where do i go
she doesn't know i don't know
no please stop No,
I don't know I'm not gonna jump in slow-mo.
I don't know where to go
All right, okay, maybe I'll work one.
Oh, please
It'll work one day I'll get out of this hell
Believe in me Okay.
Why?
Why do I go like this?
What do I do?
What do I do with you?
Oh, he doesn't know.
He doesn't know.
Okay, he knows.
Okay, I think he knew.
I thought I could camouflage!
There's so many of me!
What do I do?
What the fuck do you want from me?
What do you want from me?
Climb so many things, Roy.
Okay.
Please, let me climb.
This, let me climb.
Let me climb.
No!
Wait, let me climb.
Boy, did it let me climb.
Wait, I just want to climb.
Okay, I got this.
I got this.
And we're getting closer.
We're getting closer.
Okay, maybe I just need to throw the monkey farther away.
That's it.
The monkey just needs to be farther.
I just need to throw this monkey farther away.
Oh, here we go.
Yeah.
Wait, what the fuck?
Why are you so fast?
He heard me?
Holy shit, come on!
You don't even have ears!
Okay, maybe, okay, you do, because you can hear...
Oh, you do.
You actually do have ears.
He does have ears.
Okay.
It'll work, swanne.
We just need to keep trying.
We know what to do.
He hurt the monkey.
Ugh.
Monkey.
Go for the monkey.
Is monkey too far?
Monkey too far.
Oh, here we go.
Monkey!
Yeah.
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
No, you don't know where I am.
You don't know where I am!
I just want to...
I just want to climb!
That's all I want to do!
Please just let me climb.
I fucking hate you.
I...
There are two...
I fucking hate you.
I hate you so much Okay, there are two Monkeys, okay I got
this I'll figure this out I'm fucking so smart, I'll figure
this out Bam
I'm gonna figure it out Mark my words I'm gonna figure you
out
This is a monkey
Please, let me climb That's all I need to do That's all I
need to do What do I need to do?
I just need it to do two monkeys!
Two monkeys!
Please, please let me through.
Two monkeys.
It's so easy, first try.
I didn't think that would work.
Boom.
God, I'm so smart.
Two monkeys.
Wait, wait, who are you?
Wait!
How did you get here?
What did you do here?
First try every time right?
Oh, oh, oh what what?
What?
Did that no not me not me not me What zero they haven't died
yet we haven't died yet.
We were just listening.
It's his brother
What do I do here?
Do I...
Is it this?
What is this?
Can I even climb up this?
No.
Okay, I need to, like, figure out what this is.
What is this?
What do I do?
What are you?
I'm so confused.
Did I push this?
What are you?
What?
Ah!
I- It's easy.
Just don't die.
Oh shit, you're right.
You're right.
I do this.
And then I go, whoa!
And then...
I don't know.
I don't know what to do after this part.
He doesn't know.
I'm in the dark.
You don't know where I am.
I'm in the dark!
Okay.
Do you not just go back?
Maybe I go forward.
Maybe I don't go backwards.
Maybe I just go forward.
Like a normal person.
Maybe I don't run in a dead end.
I feel like maybe I should just went forward.
Okay.
Oh.
No.
That wasn't it.
Okay.
That wasn't...
That wasn't it.
Forward was not the answer.
I'm so...
What?
I had to do a hard clicking puzzle, and now you want me to
do another hard puzzle?
Back to back?
What is wrong with you?
I need to recharge my brain.
Okay, maybe...
Maybe...
Maybe I take the shoe, and I throw the shoe.
Give me a shoe.
Give me your shoe.
Give me, give me the shoe.
No, let me, let me throw this first.
Let me, get, get, get, get, get, get, get, get.
Fokie!
Thank you.
Fokie, thank you for the rain.
Hi, Fokie.
I am.
Hi, Fokie, thank you.
I'm on a good art stream.
Hey, everyone.
Hello, hello, hello.
Thank you so much for the follow, KC, Rainbow, Tillion.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a butt heart.
Are you playing my first?
We're doing a spooky game right now, but it's not as spooky.
I just, my brain, I just need favorite puzzles right now.
But welcome, everyone.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Also, thank you so much for the follow, Seiko and Konku.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you guys, thank you guys.
Have some more butt hearts.
Thank you.
We're stopping.
on this uh we're stuck on this on this puzzle right now big
brain and spooky game yeah so so i push this right i push
this and then okay i push this door and and i'm like what do
i okay and then this this and then and then this guy comes
down and i'm like what the fuck do i do with you wow no okay
usually usually it doesn't pick me up that fast usually you
have a few times the Him coming on Okay, so what I think I'm
thinking I think I've been stuck on this guy for a bit Thank
you guys.
Thank you all the follows.
Thank you link for the follow to Have a blood heart as well.
We got a lot of art done pokey.
I I've been playing this game for only 20 minutes and I'm
only I'm already 90% done.
Isn't that crazy?
Is that a little crazy?
Don't don't trust what my don't trust what my what my Twitch
says I've only been playing this game for 20 minutes and I'm
ready like 90% done with this game Is that crazy pokey?
I'm so fucking good.
How he's speed running?
I hope you're alive.
Well, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh Whoa, oh, oh, come on.
Come on Come on oh he's coming he's coming he's coming He
doesn't know, he doesn't know, please, oh, he doesn't know,
okay, yeah, that's her, you little bitch.
Okay, okay, okay, I need to pick up the shoe, I need to pick
up the shoe, and then, and then, and then throw the shoe,
throw, oh my god, please, don't be weak, don't be weak right
now, please, I need you to throw the shoe, please, no, oh my
god, is the shoe too big, is the shoe too big, the shoe is
too big, I picked the wrong shoe.
I picked the wrong shoe.
I'm sorry.
Please.
Okay.
We got this.
All right.
I'm leaving.
Yeah.
I can't catch you now.
Okay.
So the problem was that I picked the wrong shoe.
We're okay now.
We're okay.
We're okay, chat.
How long is it exactly?
Oh, we were never stuck on it.
We were never stuck on it.
This was my first try playing this, doing that quiz.
Yeah, never, exactly.
Never.
First try.
Hey, Ram!
Okay.
What the fuck is this piano doing here?
Boom.
Oh, I thought I died.
I thought I died.
I thought I died there.
Okay.
Can I open this?
No.
Wait, if I can just climb on all of these, right?
Yeah.
Let me just climb on these.
Okay, but what do I do after?
Oh.
Push?
No.
What the fuck?
Oh, I can climb on this.
Just grow taller.
Shit, you're right.
I can't climb on this.
Wait, there's a door.
Push.
Like, oh.
No, no, no, no, no.
Okay, climb.
Just grow taller.
Fuck, you're right.
Oh, I...
I can't just climb this.
Okay.
Boom.
Uh oh, he's pulling me?
Am I getting pulled?
No, I'm just supposed to jump here.
Let's quickly climb.
Oh,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I climb.
Can I go on?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
get your hands away from here.
Okay.
You're going to need to head to bed because I'm on data and
my power is out, but I hope you have a nice rest of your
night.
Oh, thank you, Hooty.
Thank you.
Thank you for stopping by too.
I really do appreciate it.
I hope you have a good night's rest, Hooty.
Are you planning on other games or is this long enough to
fill the week?
Oh, isn't this game like three hours maximum?
So I'm planning on playing this game for three hours.
Like for like playing this game for like the rest of the
stream.
And then we're going to play a new game tomorrow.
Because I heard this was only three hours.
Or four hours max.
Have a monkey.
Wait,
I got an idea.
Oh, no, wait, wait.
Let me back up.
I have an idea.
I do this and I go.
Yeah, you don't know where I am.
Oh, oh, wait, wait.
Stupid.
Wait, wait.
Please, please.
Let me through!
Let me through here!
No!
You stupid.
What do you do here?
How do I get out, though?
What?
How do I get out of here?
Play?
I'm so confused.
What game were you thinking?
I'm thinking I'm playing...
Visage How do I what do I do with you?
What?
How do I get out?
Let me out Let me because I was watching you run away from
him I don't know how to get out chat
Oh, there's a door Oh, I can't push it never mind I thought
I was gonna get out okay I got an idea I got okay not like
that okay okay so I have this but I don't know what to do
with this can I throw you can't even throw you what the fuck
what's the point
what the fuck would you what okay wait okay okay okay I'll
figure this out I'll use amusing maybe make the guy open oh
shit you're right you're so smart rem you're so looking
smart.
Okay, where the fuck is this thing?
Okay, I'm gonna put this here.
I'm gonna put you here.
And then...
Okay, Bunya figure out, like, how we're gonna hide, though,
afterwards.
Because I swear, if they make me do this again afterwards,
okay, where's the good hiding spot?
Do I hide here?
I should hide here, right?
Okay, maybe I might hide here.
Oh, oh my god!
Thank you so much!
The follow rock!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Have a butthart.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
What you gonna do?
Bam!
Oh.
I thought I would make more noise.
I honestly thought this would make a lot more noise.
Come on.
Make us some noise.
Oh, TV!
Oh!
Oh, TV make noises.
Please, please.
Let me, let me, let me, let me.
Let me hide.
Let me hide in here.
There's a door.
Open the door.
He doesn't know.
He's stupid.
I'm fucking...
Oh, you...
He wants a girlfriend.
He wants like, oh, wait, run?
Oh, oh.
Oh, you liar!
You liar!
Why did you tell me to run?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, you're right.
I should run.
Please, please, please.
Let me do it.
Like, he doesn't know, he doesn't know, he doesn't know, he
doesn't know.
You didn't know.
I just want to ask how you laugh.
Oh, you're just a pro for letting people know when to run.
God, I'm so good at this game.
Please.
Like, oh, God, I thought I was going to make it.
Boom.
Look at that shit.
Please try.
first try
okay okay let me let me through please let me through oh
where am I
we haven't hit the kitchen yet the kitchen is part of the
fat boy right the fat kitchen guy he's in the slout game
right I don't know if he's in this game or like or like in
the DLC because I've seen that guy a lot.
Open?
Oh, I push.
I need to...
Oh!
What?
I got past the first time!
How did I die there?
What the fuck?
Hey, let me pass the first time.
Yeah, but I got past it the first time.
So I thought he was okay.
Okay.
And then I go this.
Boom.
Kairosham's so smart.
And then...
Wait.
Oh!
What the...
What the fuck?
How?
How is that possible?
What the fuck?
My god.
What happened to the room?
So what's your favorite?
What's your favorite part about this game?
I don't know.
I guess the atmosphere is really...
I like the atmosphere of this.
It's not spooky though.
It's that it's not like I guess like there's parts where I
scream, but it's not like damn I'm spooked.
No, no, please, please.
No, no I couldn't climb I couldn't climb just then but but
ah ah
Okay, all right, all right we we open the door please please
don't please I'm holding on to it this time I don't know how
I live there I don't know I don't even know how far we are
in this game right now oh yeah I hear that I think there's
also DLC too but we're not playing the DLC after this oh
we're just starting to try and finish this one this one I
want to finish this for for today's stream what the fuck
what the fuck
wrong way
okay yeah yeah bitch that's very stupid
Get your hand away Dude, how long is he gonna Oh my god,
thank you so much for the follow, Tashi Thank you, thank
you, thank you Have a butt heart, thank you so much Oh, I
just have to run when he puts his hand up like that Okay
Stupid Okay This is a kitchen Oh, oh, oh, please, please,
please No, no No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
he still got me how was I supposed to know how do I get it
off again oh no
don't touch me oh no and climb again
Yeah, yeah, I know now.
I know now.
Hurry up!
Hurry up and slam it!
Slam it!
Please!
I don't know how long I can do this!
I don't know...
Holy shit, how strong is this thing?
No!
Is it not gonna close?
Am I gonna do this forever?
Wait,
I think- I don't think this is- I don't think this is what
I'm supposed to do, guys.
I don't think- I don't think this is what I'm supposed to
do.
I don't think it's ever gonna break.
I just realized that thing's not gonna break ever Okay, what
do I do here?
I'm looking up, I'm looking up respectfully I'm looking up
respectfully, do I?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I'm just doing
this over and over again I, I don't know what to do I don't
know what to do, ah, ah, ah, don't touch me, no, touch me,
Is this?
No.
What am I doing?
You're in the middle, pull that.
How though?
How do I pull this?
I can't pull this at all.
I can't, I can't pull anything.
What do I pull?
What do I?
Oh, this.
Okay.
Do I pull you?
No, no, he's gonna pinch me!
No, no!
Okay, wait.
Okay, I know now, I know now, I know now, I know now, I know
now.
Okay, okay, okay, my brain is working.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I'm figuring it out.
I'm figuring it out.
I'm figuring, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm trying, chat.
Oh, no.
Yeah!
Ah, stupid.
Wait, there's more?
Oh, shit, there's more.
I celebrated too early.
That was nice.
I must have known there was more.
Come on.
Yeah, it's stupid!
You see that?
Oh, wait, his arm's still grabbing me!
Yeah.
Thank you, stupid.
Yeah, I'm so smart.
I'm so smart.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
What's he gonna do now?
What are you gonna do now, huh?
I'm deep banging his arm.
now huh yeah that's right that's right yeah progress we're
making progress
the lair oh the lair sounds spooky you crippled that guy
dude he deserves it he deserves it looking that's what you
that's what you get for getting long arms looking just be
like the rest of us for short arms
god you let me hydrate because i feel like i won't be able
to hydrate later
holy shit my arm broke there all right
okay hopefully no more creepy ass monsters why am i saying
they are all scary his head dude we haven't seen the he's
not he haven't seen the chef yet yeah i guess so he i
thought it was him That was the creepy guy.
Did I grab onto this?
Oh, I do.
Wee.
There's a chef.
There he is.
I see you.
I know you're next.
I remember the chef's being the next boss.
Oh.
Oh, I'm hungry.
again oh no i'm hungry just eat those bodies here isn't this
meat why can't you eat this i don't understand just open it
meat is meat
look he tried to figure out this game is the best thing ever
oh my god eating people now the chef always creeped me out
he's haunted my my nightmare several times oh shit is he
creepier than long boy how can he be creepier than long boy
yeah i'm gonna eat you i'm gonna eat you oh yeah that's
right yeah wait i'm not eating this oh okay i thought i was
gonna eat the rat i thought it was gonna i thought it was
gonna eat the rat wait i do i do why wouldn't it let me eat
it him let me do let me eat you yeah oh my god oh my god
holy shit
um stupid rat
sales i'm like kind of sad it's pretty sad like poor rat
Why did I join in?
Oh, she just ate a rat.
Raw.
She could have at least cooked it, you know.
I guess I ever ate rats.
Apparently, you can eat cooked rats in somewhere in the
world.
Food is food.
Can I push this?
I push you.
Oh, what?
It won't let me in.
It pushed me back.
At least you're not hungry anymore, yeah.
ratty rat world here
oh let me up let me up let me up what's that oh that's the
chef that's the chef there he is okay there he is there he
is There he is.
Oh, you're ugly!
I guess if anyone chatted on it, I'll put the reason my god,
dude, I don't know.
What do you mean?
Look at- Whoa, no!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, why are you
screaming?
What the fuck?
That's it.
He's screaming so I screamed too.
If you hate me, because you're still alive.
I was like, why are you screaming?
Why scream at you?
I
look like a running banana.
I forget how do I do this?
He doesn't know.
He's stupid.
On you.
He just wants to consume.
Maybe I don't run.
Maybe that's the play here.
Maybe I just don't run.
Can I hide here?
I look.
I am looking respectfully.
Where do I hide here, though?
Oh.
I hide.
Can't see me.
You stupid.
Where do I hide there, though?
I don't know where to hide.
Okay, where do you go?
Where do you go?
Wait, you guys want to see his face?
I mean...
Well, I can't move away.
You hide in his belly They look respectfully I'm looking
respectfully at him Look at me has hair Oh wait what the
fuck Oh shit no he doesn't have hair He just ripped his,
that's not his skin
Oh he doesn't know, he doesn't know You don't know, you
don't know, you don't know, you don't know, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no Oh, you have a butter.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'm looking respectfully.
I'm sorry.
Please.
Oh.
Okay.
All right, all right, Cole, here you go, Cole.
All right, looking respectfully at him.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my.
Oh, no!
You don't know!
What?
How?
How does he know?
Yeah, he doesn't.
He doesn't know.
I'm looking respectfully.
he doesn't know
he had a cut feeling oh my god I don't know how to do this
one
make a break for it the last time I did that I got caught
go here
don't get caught
looking respectfully that's my strategy looking respectfully
I'm a very respectful person.
You bitch.
Looking respectfully.
What?
Looking.
Looking respectfully.
How?
I'm a respectful person.
I'm respecting you Oh, I don't like this I don't like this
Okay, I need to know his What is he doing?
Cutting some fishies Okay Okay, okay Alright He doesn't know
He doesn't know that's my heart Going bottom, bottom, bottom
He doesn't know Yeah, he's stupid Stupid look it out there's
a key where the fuck do i get the key
okay okay this is how i do it okay i'm looking okay okay oh
it's on him oh okay
all right
all right i just need to knock him out Great.
That's all I have to do.
I'm going to knock you out.
God, if I die here, I have to do this all over again.
I don't want to die.
I don't want to redo this.
I don't want to keep looking.
What's over there?
What is this?
Okay.
What?
What the?
What the fuck?
What the fuck was that?
What?
What the fuck?
What the fuck did I just do?
Ema malfunctioned.
Look at the fuck.
That actually scared me.
What do I do here?
What?
Oh shit, hey.
Yeah.
Oh, what are you?
What is this?
What?
Wait.
Where am I?
Hey, Ray.
I don't know what I did.
I actually don't know what I did.
This is a checkpoint?
Oh Okay He
Whoa, whoa, whoa, who are you?
Oh, oh, no, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, I'm so sorry I said no you don't know you don't know oh
he knew he knew
I'm so sorry I'm sorry for waking you up I'm gonna go
How he teleported
How the heck did you do that?
Okay, okay Oh shit That's why they're double toilets They're
twins Is that what twins do?
Do you guys poop with each other?
Are there any twins in chat?
Is there any twins in chat?
Is that what you guys do?
We have toilets next to it.
Okay, cookie boy.
Why else is there like double toilets?
You guys poop next to each other like that.
Look, look, see?
Any twin sees a child?
I'm a twin in depth.
Are you hiding?
Fool, you don't have to lie to us.
You don't have to.
It's just a solid logic.
You don't have to lie to us.
Don't worry.
It's our little secret.
Don't worry, fool.
What if he poots, but he needs two toilets?
Woo!
He don't know.
Stupid.
okay where did he go
okay all right all right we go down we go down boom I'm so
fucking smart he didn't fucking know stupid twin he's the
stupid twin clearly okay now we have to do this again now we
have to do this again no wait we're is he oh there he is can
you go under here we can okay
okay okay okay okay I'm looking respectfully I'm looking
very respectfully right now you stupid bitch you stupid
bitch you stupid bitch no no no no he doesn't know he
doesn't I'm here!
Stupid fucking gnome.
He doesn't know.
It's stupid.
No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Please, please, get in, get in the key, get in the key, get
in, get in, get in, get in!
Why did I pick up the log?
Why did it pick up the log just then?
Let me in!
Wait!
Oh!
Let me out!
Okay.
I'm late.
Where do I go?
Jump.
Okay.
Oh, oh, me.
Crimbo it to you.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Oh, shit.
I'm making some sausages.
Thank you so much.
How will butter it?
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Meat.
No more meat.
Do I keep doing this?
No.
What is this?
Oh.
Bye?
Bye.
you know she's she's under but you can't duck since that
requires energy okay all right i need to get this meat in
how do i put more sausages more sausages please
we we
Okay.
All right, all right.
All right, no, no, no.
Get in, get in the hole.
Is this Arby's?
Welcome to Arby's.
All right.
Boop.
Okay.
And then I just do the churn turn.
and then oh my god it looks like poop I'm so uncomfortable
is this enough okay I need more that may look sus oh shit I
can pick up a sausage oh my god it's so fucking wrong
Thank you so much for the follow, Rubio.
Thank you, thank you.
I do appreciate it.
I will butthart.
I don't know.
Okay, we go up.
Mystery meat is the best one you meat.
How do I get more meat?
I need more meat.
We need more.
Oh Where what okay, I can't fucking climb clearly I need
more meat
Oh Give oh what the fuck give give me oh Wait Did I fuck up
What what How do I how full brain?
Okay, clearly it's not that thing because I can't get on top
of it so what the fuck do I do I bucket do I move you bucket
bucket bucket no no bucket what the fuck should be enough
okay let me try again maybe I climb oh it won't let me churn
more meat me well are you sure it's enough dude i don't
think it's enough guys can i climb climb no it keeps just
keeps making me make more meat
i need two more sausages but where do i do i i'm gonna bring
you with me maybe i have i bring you with me okay okay no
okay no I'll go back up.
I'm going to go back up.
I need one more.
Wait, can I go over here?
Oh!
There's a little hole here.
Oh.
Oh, hey.
Uh.
We're in.
I'm so smart.
Look at that.
Oh!
What are you?
Oh shit!
Oh, I fucking fell!
Okay, how do I get up here?
God damn it!
I'm trying... I'm trying to figure out how to...
Okay, okay, okay.
Please, let me up here!
I don't know how to get up!
Okay.
Okay, that's not it.
That's not it.
Please, let me...
Let me up.
Please, let me up.
I don't want to get up.
Sorry, thank you so much.
You can't think of stuff to Acer.
Thank you.
Woo!
Can I get some...
break nights uh real quick for for for for for uh for czar
and azir and that's the best time to eat while watching this
i see it's okay what god damn it give me up
please please let me up let me up i don't know how to get up
here
okay okay i keep maybe okay I fucking I clearly not clearly
it got jumping was not the was not the right idea how do we
get up I'm angry okay maybe maybe this will work again maybe
this will work all right no okay now they what the me Oh, I
can't get to this meat, though.
There's no meat here.
Like, it won't let me pick up the meat here.
Oh, it won't let me pick up the meat.
Up!
I'm trying!
I'm trying to give up!
Let me make you into sausages!
Fire!
Is it fire?
I don't want to do.
Okay, I give up.
I clearly, this isn't it.
I don't think this is it, chat.
I don't think this was the right idea.
I don't.
Wait.
Can I pull this?
Wait, is that me?
Wait, this is me!
You're looking, you're all blind!
You were all blind!
This was...
We're all blind!
We're all fucking blind!
We're so stupid!
We're all stupid.
That was it.
We were all stupid.
It's okay.
Nintendo!
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Thank you so much for the raid.
Thank you.
We had a good stream.
What were you streaming?
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Hello, everyone.
Hi.
We're playing Little Nightmares.
Uh, thank you.
Thank you so much.
I hope we had a really good stream in 10.
Also, thank you so much for the follow-up, Sledgy Gamer, and
Unravel Persona.
Thank you, thank you.
Have a, have a but hearts.
Thank you so much, guys.
And Dutch Potato, thank you.
Okay, I'm trying to, Little Nightmares so good.
Yeah, we're using our brains right now.
We've been trying to find this last piece of meat.
for like 20 years and it was right here it was looking it
was right here the last season of me and we didn't know so
we were having some problems we're all stupid Chad and I
were both stupid together thank you so much for the follow
fish and super Joshy thank you thank you have some have some
but hearts thank you thank you I'm not blind I've seen the
game before Vicky, everyone's like, yeah, just go up, just
go up, that's how you do it, and I'm like, up, up?
Vicky, Vicky, trying to get up, up, and it wasn't working.
All right, some sausage, let's go, bull.
Yeah, you know, up, yeah, up, Vicky, clearly I was at the
wrong up, please, oh, thank God, oh, this isn't real true.
the movie's simple
oh yeah okay we've only been playing this game for like 20
minutes and already 90% done is that crazy guys for all your
new viewers out there we're making a new world record also
do not trust the timestamp of my stream because it's broken
right now but i've only been playing it for 20 minutes
run i'm gonna fucking guinness world records right here
little nightmares first try blind run yeah it's only 20
minutes but it says no no it says it's the zero it the zero
is 23 sorry i'm at 23 minutes the zero is at the wrong place
it's bugged right now she has a 3d mod she's even using some
kind of dice for hand cat yeah yeah i have a hand tracker so
trying to convince you are you better playing the games than
getting emos done yeah yeah perfect where's this key
okay what the am i doing where's the key look look see this
tech i'm b hopping this is some like a speed run tech right
here my b hops look at that like
okay where the how the fuck do it oh there's a switch here i
was like i was like where is the key oh what the fuck whoa
whoa get home oh no no
yeah but it's broken too Okay, alright, anyway, I was, I'm
fucking, anyway, what happened?
I passed out for a second.
I don't know what happened, I just passed out for a second.
Anyway, this is a speedrun.
This is a speedrun, guys.
Oh, I'm running now.
I know now.
You can't see me, stupid.
Oh, oh, get away.
Gee.
Please leave.
It's stupid.
Yeah
Oh, let me let me through let me through wait wait why can't
I get out?
Please oh
Stupid Oh my
god Please leave please leave
Okay, okay he doesn't know doesn't know he doesn't know
do you think he can't see me do you think he can't see me by
hiding here I'm such a good speeder I'm so fast look at this
oh gross that's disgusting he doesn't look No, Pamela.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
So thank you so much for the follow final boss.
Thank you.
Okay,
uh, I don't know what his pattern is gonna be.
I'm gonna look at him for a bit just in case i need i i'm
just i don't want to go out right now i'm just scared i
don't want to redo this whole thing i don't want to redo it
he reminds me of hr hre stuff but extra meaty what's he
doing is he not gonna turn around oh he's just gonna keep
chopping meat okay i'm i'm flying
Bye.
Oh, I do the grinder.
Please.
No, no, no, no, no.
Please, let me, let me get the key.
Ah, let me go.
Can't you run faster, you little child.
Okay.
Boom.
oh please run faster child run faster please please run
faster the key ah child please oh he can't see me he doesn't
know he doesn't know he's stupid You're stupid, please
Holy shit, okay, all right, okay, he didn't know he didn't
know He likes critical information This is fucking idiot
What do I do after I know he was like the fuck do it oh here
okay look at that see looking easy so easy I wasn't scared
at all what the fuck do I is this a plunger do I do I pick
you up what do you know what the fuck oh I climb I'm my home
okay No, that's not what I do.
What the fuck do I do here?
Oh.
I climb.
Oh, oh, I do climb.
I do climb.
There's a hole here.
No, he freaks out and then excels at the table.
Okay.
Alright, I don't know what I'm supposed to do here now.
I'm just gonna...
Look, he's doing this.
dishes oh they are twins look at that they're twins look at
that i told you guys that's why he has they had two toilets
because twins like poop next to each other that's what twins
do
that's what this game taught me
oh i'm supposed to go here
oh okay i have to can
i get out from here
He doesn't know.
There's another stupid.
They know nothing.
I'm so confident I'm going to drink some tea while I watch
them.
Because they know nothing.
They don't know shit.
Stupid.
okay where do i oh no no
oh he doesn't know they don't know like you idiots i just
read through glasses i was like oh my god no he doesn't know
okay oh okay no no no no no no They could smell fear.
I hear nothing.
What are you guys talking about?
I don't feel shit.
This is a zoo.
You idiot.
Okay, what the fuck do I do?
Wait, why is he looking under the tables?
You're not supposed to do that!
What do I do here after?
Can I go up?
Up!
Okay, not up.
Not up.
What?
Really?
How do I- What?
I'm so confused!
Here?
What the fuck?
What do you- What do you want me to do?
I- I don't know what to do!
What do I do?
I just turned it on, but now I don't know what's next after.
Uh-huh.
At the door?
Oh, door.
Wait, there's a door here.
Okay, okay.
We're waiting.
We're waiting for this freak to get out.
Please leave.
Please leave, Mr. Mr. Go back to the in the other kitchen.
I don't trust.
I don't know if I can trust you guys door.
Okay.
What's on the door?
Why wouldn't it let me go up?
Wait, what?
I can turn it again.
What the fuck?
I'm so confused.
How do I get to the hooks, though?
How do I get up to you?
You're so tall.
I don't want to do this again.
I need to do it.
Okay, I gotta...
I'll make it past here.
Stupid.
I'm just gonna hide here.
Okay.
Alright.
Where is this hook leading to?
Okay.
Oh, one scary.
Okay, thank you so much, the bids are on.
Okay, all right.
Okay, I'm looking.
I'm looking respectfully.
The dish tower.
Oh, there's a dish tower.
Okay.
I was like, what dish tower?
I'm looking respectfully.
Please leave.
Leave.
Leave!
Oh my god.
Why you keep washing your dishes?
Just buying new plates?
Oh, I get up.
How do I go up?
I'm getting up.
Ah!
No!
Please!
Let me go!
Okay.
Oh, please!
Yeah!
Stupid!
You can't get me!
I don't know.
What are you gonna do?
Nothing.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Whoa.
No.
He doesn't know.
Wait.
Ah.
Yeah, it's freaking idiot.
Look at that, so good.
That's right.
The broken bottle on you.
The fear of trying to do that again made me fucking love,
made me like speedrun that shit.
I did not want to do that again.
I did not want to wait again.
I didn't want to fucking wait and hide again.
Well, I washed dishes when you just buy new ones.
Exactly.
This is like, you know what the biggest brain is?
Just buy paper plates and then recycle them when you're
done.
Like, you never have to do dishes.
You just recycle your plates afterwards.
Isn't that so smart?
That's a...
Look at that.
I'm bee hopping.
That run felt like a Super Bowl touchdown run.
Holy shit.
Convenient ladder.
No, right?
That seagull?
Holy shit!
Is that land?
Oh, no.
That's just boats.
Look at them.
look at that's a boat and then another boat there they go
look at um look at the cattle oh I
was trying to grab onto it how was I supposed to know I
didn't okay please let me grab onto it where the fuck are I
supposed to go
Okay, okay, clearly, wait, okay, this time I can do it.
Okay, maybe?
Wait, no, I- I know you're supposed to touch this!
What else are you supposed to- See?
I just didn't know what to send up my directions.
I was just blind.
I don't fucking know.
I just didn't know my directions, clearly.
Okay.
Here, I'm so- holy shit, how big is this ship?
Look at this big ass boat.
Damn perception, yeah.
Oh, look, there's a seagull.
Look at there.
Look at the size of a seagull.
Look at him.
Look at him over there.
Jesus Christ You're big boys
You're like Big boys
What the fuck is this game?
Dude, I don't even know I don't even know, Fierce here We've
been playing this game for like 20 minutes and I still don't
know I still don't know what we're doing I mean I don't
I jumped and freaked out because I didn't know there was
shit below me.
Speedrunner skipping the cut.
There were cutscenes?
No, it was just like fucking chonkers.
Look at them.
Look at these chonkers.
Almost detective fart.
There's a really good fear I still won't share because
spoilers.
It's been 20 minutes, 30 minutes ago.
Sorry, I meant I meant 23 minutes.
Sorry, I'm at 23 minutes, guys.
I'm playing this game for 23 minutes.
I still don't know what we're doing.
Oh, shit.
Look at her.
She's the only non-chonky one.
Oh, whoa!
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
That's too busy looking at her.
Thank you so much for the follow-up, Lately Glenn.
have a butter thank you thank you zero i'm sorry i i blinked
for a second i i i blinked for a second chat i'm sorry so
anyway i haven't died yet i was just blinking oh no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no oh shit sorry i passed out for
a sec what happened i don't know what happened anyway zero
deaths i i passed out that.
I keep forgetting.
I'm trying to do bee hopping and I keep forgetting that
there's like a gap here.
Okay, all right, all right, all right.
I was distracted by girl.
Yeah, girl distracted me.
Do I get up here?
Oh, I get up here.
Look at them chonkers.
Oh, lady.
Boom.
Dude, look at the speedrun!
Look at that!
I'm gonna look at them too.
Oh, where are they going?
Where are you going?
Damn, look at the wrinkles down there.
There's no one rocking the ship.
True.
Oh shit, they're eating.
What the fuck?
He looks like a rat.
Look at him.
Prepare to run.
What?
No!
I don't want to run again.
Oh!
Please!
Where do I go?
Oh, I'm up, up, up, up, up.
Like, you idiot.
Wait, what the fuck?
Like, how you fuck that's so bad you still live?
I don't know how the fuck I survived that.
I don't know how.
Like, stupid.
like you oh my god please don't grab me please don't grab me
oh oh my god thinking idiot what do i do here don't eat the
walking cheese
i'm trying to figure out what to do here because i don't
want to go climb that and then get fucking Eden what the
fuck is that chair move is it here what
am I doing what am I doing
whoa I just got it what the fuck I just so entertaining Lisa
thank you so much for the hundred bits thank you thank you
Are you glad you're enjoying the stream?
Lisa, I'm glad, I'm glad.
Boop.
Okay.
Where do I go, though?
That's the thing.
Let me up!
Okay, clearly that's not it.
okay
gotta run down the table huh wait why is there a chair here
oh stupid I just pushed the chair oh never mind that was a
dead end that was a that was a dead end that's just that's a
stupid fucking achievement oh I hug him what the fuck why do
I need to hug you Can I throw you off?
I'm just gonna...
What if I...
I'm just gonna give it...
I'm bringing you with me.
Bring you with me.
Wait,
I can feed him?
I'm gonna feed him.
Oh, I can't.
I can't feed him.
Alright, I guess you're just gonna watch me die.
I guess you're just gonna watch me die.
I have a gig random ass.
No.
Wait.
Let me up.
Okay.
What did I do?
Thank you so much for the follow!
Kiyoshi, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I do appreciate it.
Have a butt heart.
Thank you.
Climb the chair, maybe?
Like, idiot.
look at him look at him he just eats it and then and then it
comes back out look at that
okay that wasn't it
okay anyway here we go again here we go again Dodge them all
trying.
Look at it.
Oh, maybe if I do bee hops, I'm going to do bee hops.
That's it.
We're going to use the tech.
We're going to use the little nightmares tech that we
learned.
Look at this.
Look at that.
Yeah.
Oh, this is it.
This is it.
No, this wasn't it.
This wasn't it.
No.
We're so close.
The bee.
deck we're so close we know what to do now we know what to
do it's the bee hops is the bee hops zero deaths zero deaths
zero deaths yeah it's been 20 40 minutes and we haven't died
yet is that crazy guys you think yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah shit.
I knew learning B-Hops was gonna save me.
Look at that.
Wait.
That's what you had to do.
Just B-Hop.
That's chat waiting, right?
That's amazing.
Can't believe how amazing proven crumple you are.
I know.
Isn't that crazy, guys?
That's what's pretty cash money move of you.
That's what B-Hop taught me.
I knew B-Hopping would be well it would help me sooner or
later i knew it and i eat my bread okay you're always hungry
just eat no well when he had when he had when she had food
she cooking doesn't eat it i'm gonna spoil a
bitch he kept like starving and eating like live rats and
everything too and now that she has real food she's like no
i gotta get out
ASMR of, like, the meaning is, like, I don't know how I feel
about it.
They're like, it's, like, ASMR.
This game makes me many things.
Hungry is not one of them.
Can I go over here?
Oh, shit, I can go over here.
What am I going to do here, though?
What does he want me to do here?
Whoa, wait, wait.
I don't want to be here anymore.
I don't want to be here.
anymore.
Please, please, let me, let me, let me go.
So, you idiot.
I can't.
Stupid.
Am I, do I jump over him?
Oh my god, why are you so fast?
That procession.
Whoa.
Oh no.
No!
No, not you.
Not you.
Leave me alone.
I'm gonna get out of here.
Toilet.
He doesn't know.
Leave me alone.
Toilet paper.
I need
to hug it for comfort.
Okay, I have to go up here.
How do I?
How do I go up?
Up.
Okay, not like that.
True horror is if he starts pooping.
Oh my god.
I do not need that.
ASMR right now.
I do not need the poop ASMR from this game.
How do they flush?
They don't have any flushers.
Pull a vanguard because they didn't go down the toilet tree.
Oh.
It's hiding with the paper, not like he grabbed and wiped
his ass out.
Okay, okay.
Then you have to do this, right?
Okay, no.
That skin looks like, looks like a bath.
Boom.
Thank you so much for the follow shadows.
Thank you.
Have a have a but heart.
Thank you so much.
The push door door.
No, not door.
Hello fuck.
Do we climb up?
Can I climb you up?
No.
Oh shit.
No, wait.
I don't know what to do.
I thought I don't know just leaving I can't look
wait oh wait wait wait wait wait toilet paper up up this is
where I live now I guess I guess I live here now break the
mirror how the fuck do I break the mirror boom oh please let
me out let me out can oh he gave me a can from earlier he
gave me a cat okay okay maybe maybe wait wait wait okay
maybe it's not the cat maybe okay okay okay okay maybe not
okay Oh, shit!
I broke the cat!
I broke the mirror!
I'm sorry!
Hey, open the door.
Open the door.
Oh.
Oh, do I just go on the other side?
Okay.
I thought he was gonna come back.
Had some lots of catch you later.
Uh, go get that one on the record.
All right, that's the city.
Thank you so much for hitting all of us tonight.
night i hope you have a good night's rest i hope you have a
good night's rest thank you for hanging out with us i didn't
think that would work either i thought i was supposed to i
thought we were supposed to break the mirror and then like
the guy will like make noise and stuff and then and then and
then the guy would like open the door and we'll get out i
didn't know that was another room i thought that was just i
was i actually didn't think that was another room
oh shit sorry my thingy is being weird let me Are you
calorie?
Okay, there you go.
Okay, have a good rest of the stream.
Alright, all dear.
Thanks for hanging out with us.
I really do appreciate it.
Come here, get a rest of the day.
Ah.
Alright, let me...
Where the fuck is he?
Oh, he's chopping.
He's doing the chop chop.
Chop, chop, chop.
Chop, chop.
Jump, jump.
Yeah, that's not gonna fuck me over.
Did I go down?
Ha!
I don't know, sorry, here.
Why are you running away from Tudor's security?
Look how ugly they are!
Juki!
That's why.
They're freaks.
Juki's intelligence scares me.
I know I'm so smart.
I know.
It scares me, too, how smart I am sometimes.
Leave me alone.
No.
Just keep running.
Let's keep running straight.
Oh, no.
Now it's down.
What?
Oh, wait.
to the polygory.
Thank you.
I have learned.
Okay, clearly we don't keep going straight.
We don't keep running straight.
I have learned that it's just not only straight.
It's not just straight.
It's down too.
It's also down.
All right.
I'm not.
Guys, it's like, oh, please don't touch me.
Please.
don't touch me don't touch me okay okay down down down down
down yeah the b hop the b hop oh my god get out ah yeah what
you gonna fucking ah ah no b hop b hop b hop no b hop no
please oh my god
Oh my god, the bee hop, the bee hop.
He's like, idiot.
My beard's amazing.
That's right.
All right, let me look at him.
Oh, they're just eating now.
It's hard to end stream think of what it just happened.
They're just chilling.
Nothing.
I gotcha fucking two.
Three noises took you for it after being chased.
Look at them.
They're just eating.
Oh my god, Sire.
Thank you so much for gifting a sub to Admiral.
Thank you.
Woo.
Can we get some?
Can we get some Fortnite too quick for Sire and Admiral for
the looking sub?
Okay.
I break the doll.
Where's the doll?
Shit, did I forgot about the doll?
I forgot about the doll.
I thought there was a doll here.
Is it back there?
Oh, no, I forgot!
Let me back in!
It won't let me back in!
It's closed!
Oh, we don't need this stupid doll.
Oh, shit, I need it.
Are you hungry?
How could you be hungry?
There was food and food.
Everywhere!
Stupid girl!
How are you hungry?
There was so much food!
I died from hunger after not- Aw, you stupid idiot!
There was so much food.
There was food everywhere!
Yeah, fuck this gnome!
Fuck this gnome!
Feed me!
Oh!
Wow!
Well, I was fed.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Vanessa.
Why not?
Thank you.
I have my heart.
Well, I got fed.
So...
It was not what I Uh Um It's not what I expected But I
didn't But I got fed I I got fed though They just only got
Sire They give her another gifted sub To Ness Thank you
Thank you You get more Barbie nights real quick For Sire and
Ness to give this up that team i had to kill all you noticed
that didn't you i had to you're running away from the
monsters but you're the monster all along oh my god there's
something wrong with this child what's that something wrong
with this child i did not think that's what he she was gonna
wait there's the lady lady me oh okay bye lady wait oh
pretty lady oh it's my turn it's my turn lady this is me all
right all right oh Another achievement we just got.
I'm gonna drink some tea while we wait here.
Hmm.
Wait, is this a cutscene?
It's a cutscene.
Oh, it's not.
It's not a cutscene.
I just moved.
It was not a cutscene, by the way.
I didn't even see this game before, but I'm hardly laughing
right now.
Like, I don't know if that's a good thing or a bad thing.
Okay, let me go this way.
I thought it was a cutscene because it was zoomed in.
I was, like, just waiting.
Okay.
Do do do Rolling up
Oh, she's singing
Hey, it's me Hey, oh, oh, oh I think I died I
Oh, oh hey
I I I didn't expect that.
I I I I really I I didn't expect that I don't know I was
like hey there lady hey there
When she sees you this on my sister's Robert
I don't know what to do We will cause it open?
Oh no, not open You want me to do lady?
up oh shim's so smart oh wait I need what up oh what do I do
lady lady what do you want me to do lady hmm
Okay, she didn't like that.
She didn't like it when I...
She didn't like that I kept jumping up and down.
Fall down on the closet knobs.
Oh, shit.
You're right.
Let's try that.
Dumb.
Hello, original.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, I didn't jump.
I didn't jump just then.
No.
Nope, that wasn't it.
That wasn't it.
Also, thank you so much for the follow, Chris.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a... have a butthart.
Thank you so much.
What do I do?
I'm jumping.
What do you want me to do, lady?
Here?
What?
What do you want me to do, lady?
What do you want me to do?
I can't even look at you?
Stupid lady.
Okay.
Okay, I got, I know what to do.
I know.
I like how something's sneaking inside and in here.
Oh, shit, I...
Oh, wait.
Stupid lady.
Like, we're just like, damn, we should, we should, like, try
and climb to it, and then I have crouched.
Look, I have a perfectly good explanation for this.
I just, look, she's pretty, okay?
She's, she's a really pretty lady.
And we haven't seen any ladies in a while.
it's been a while since we saw all these pretty ladies okay
breaking the maze you fucking sim I'm sneaking I'm sneaking
I'm sneaking I'm not good at stealth I'm bad at stealth I'm
sorry guys and then she coming over hello please lady lady
to be fair we forgot it too yeah it wasn't just we all
forgot we forgot it together got the key okay okay i don't
think of what the game's about but i'm loving it so far i
don't even know either i've been playing this game for like
three hours already and i don't even oh already and I almost
I accidentally added an extra zero by mistake guys can you
keep sneaking I don't right wait
I'm gonna break you I'm gonna break you first oh yeah 30
minutes I'll be playing this game for 30 minutes I still
don't know what the fuck we're doing guys thank you so much
for the follow and sir original thank you thank you I do
appreciate it thank you so much No buttharts yet, because I
have to hold on to this key while I'm running, so I can't
give you a butthart yet, but I will as soon as I get to the
bottom of this house.
Okay, okay, boom.
All right, here's a butthart for you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
All right, I think we're almost to the end, too.
Lady, lady, I'm sorry, lady, lady, please.
Oh, lady.
I'm sorry, lady.
I'm sorry.
Are you guys seeing a playthrough?
I know you're so stupid, but I'm not going to help you.
Oh.
She all has one waiting for you this time.
What the fuck?
Oh, okay.
I remember my first but heart, I was like, Nani, what did
she say?
Oh, there's a mirror here.
Oh, hey, look at this is the mirror.
Do I break it?
Ugh.
Oh!
I'm gonna carry you.
I'm gonna carry you around.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Dude, dude, dude, dude.
Oh!
Dude, dude!
Hey lady.
Lady.
Look, I got a mirror, lady!
Lady?
Lady!
Oh!
Oh no!
Okay, okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Where's the light?
Lay...
Oh, oh, oh, I don't even I'm so smart.
I didn't even know I didn't even know I didn't even know I
didn't even know I just wanted to carry a mirror around.
I just wanted I just wanted to carry a mirror around and I'm
so fucking smart.
Where are you, lady?
Lady, lady, lady, lady, lady, please lady look at yourself.
Lady, lady!
Oh shit, where's the light?
Where is it?
Welcome back, Autumn!
Lady,
lady, lady, lady, lady, lady, lady, lady, lady!
how many how how much do you need to look at yourself how
much more how much more
please get up get i'm winning am i winning son am i winning
your health bar is high oh bye lady
Hey, what?
Lady?
This is...
Why?
Why, lady?
What?
Am I gonna eat her?
Lady.
Oh Oh Oh What the fuck Oh my god Oh my god I was just joking
I ate her Oh my god Oh my god
Ross took it Holy, are you people took it?
Oh shit You did the worst of us Oh my god Am I lady now?
Am I the lady?
I'm lady now
okay okay i was gonna be like is this gonna be a cutscene
again but then i moved i knew i i knew i was gonna have to
move this time i am the apex predator joki's the lady i'm
the lady now it is i oh shem is a holy shit what the fuck oh
my god what lady dokey yeah yeah oh my god
yeah that's right that's right i'm gonna fucking walk up to
all of them oh no she really is here there what the fuck is
going on yeah oh yeah Small people rise up.
I have no, I don't know.
I became the lady.
And now I'm consuming everyone.
Hard hacks for everyone.
Oh my god, I'm tired.
Thank you so much, Rilu.
We're gonna get to some Tamushi guy.
Thank you.
Oh Wait, can we get some bark nights real quick for the two?
Thank you again Am I
out I'm finally out I need some clouds too some clouds too.
Sorry.
Oh shit.
That was it We did it We did it We looking did it
35 minutes it only took us 35 minutes oh shit you're sorry i
mean 30 minutes and 30 minutes zero deaths dude that has to
be world record that has to be a speed run record right
there looking jokie bird 30 minutes zero deaths b hop
extraordinary holy fucking i still don't know what the just
happened i just i became the lady that's all I became the
lady, chat.
Lady don't even win.
Alright, so now you're done.
You're seeing that the main character, aka 6, is the lady's
daughter.
Oh, shit, I am the lady.
Yates the souls of the meatmen.
I'm the lady now.
I am the lady.
Holy shit, that was a fun game, guys.
I really had a lot of fun.
It wasn't always a good night when you stream.
Oh, that's so sweet.
Thank you What are games we plan to play?
I think we're going to do Vassage tomorrow Because I want to
do like a horror a horror game like we're gonna do four to
five horror streams before the end of October And I think
we're gonna do Vassage Tomorrow I don't know how long
Vassage is so we'll see we'll see because I want to do like
a different horror game each stream So that means like we're
gonna play four different horror games The lady become the
lady.
Because she was familiar how to move around the ship.
Yeah, that seems right.
That seems right.
I want to know who the fuck were the gnomes.
The gnomes.
What are your games?
I don't know yet.
I haven't decided yet.
But yeah, I'm like really honestly.
I decided games like two out.
Like I think like I decided games very last minute.
So I don't know what we're going to do after.
After Vassage.
Seven, eight, nine, but six, eight, or four.
Oh my God, yes.
Also that the lady wanted to be the most beautiful and made
this place to make sure everyone ate too much and became
fat.
Oh, so they were ugly.
So they were ugly.
I knew it.
So I wasn't being mean when I called them ugly.
And she might have had an accent, hence the mask.
And while all mirrors were broken, she died due to her
reflection.
oh shit so she was ugly too and she died i heard a little
sesame sheet number that she's very scary game to play which
time so are you and if you don't mind me asking i'm in na
pst pacific time um you aren't you weren't you weren't when
you were just hungry damn sneakers were right all over oh my
gosh um died from ugly state
fuck that's too real man that's too real she's in no time so
she dumps the streams yeah i stream my own time zone it's my
own time zone guys we are gonna have start having any
streams though since we did hit our sub goal um or 300 sub
goal uh so we're gonna have a one any stream a week and our
first any stream is gonna be on tuesday i've not decided
what time yet like i need to figure out the time so I just
know it's going to be on Tuesday.
It's going to be a stream before 10 p.m.
That's for sure.
Patrick's Prophecy.
Everyone was so ugly.
They all died.
My eyes burn when I look in the mirror too.
So in order to be human, we must eat humans.
No, in order to be a lady, you must eat the lady.
The lady said, damn, I won't eat ugly.
I guess I'll just die.
Oh my god.
I hope you guys had a good time.
I had a really good time, too.
You're the power of ugliness.
You out-uglied the ugliness.
But I hope you guys had a good time, like, looking, watching
me play this game.
There was enough.
Was there eight subs?
Was there really eight subs?
Because that's 304.
304.
We started with 300, though, Roy.
It was my first time here.
And, um, and that was great.
I'm glad you enjoyed the stream.
So your stream on drunk hour or crackhead hour?
Like, I don't know.
I just stream whenever, really.
I just be like, shit, I need a little stream.
And then I go be like, fuck, there, fuck, here we go.
It is 2 a.m.
for me.
Crembo, thank you so much for the tier one sub.
Thank you.
Woo!
Can I have some break nights real quick for Crembo?
Thank you, thank you, thank you, Crembo.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, guys.
Holy shit.
Okay, let me count.
One, two, three, three.
four um five uh uh six seven oh we did we did hit eight we
could do a little giveaway we could do a little giveaway um
i'm gonna yeah i'm gonna look good let's go let's go um yeah
that's nine now you're hilarious i love this stream oh thank
you sick i think i'm glad you guys might have money because
i don't do a lot for i just recently started doing more
variety streams because i usually just stream art and stuff
but but apparently people say i'm funny so they're like you
should do variety streams and because you're funny it's fun
to watch i'm like fuck am i like and i just say um like i
just say like i just say whatever comes out of my mouth so i
never like i um i never like really know what uh what i'm
doing when i play i usually don't stream video games this is
like It's like, I always get really, I get nervous about
doing variety streams because I don't know if you guys would
watch it, but I'm glad you do.
I'm glad you guys enjoy whenever I, like, fucking say stupid
shit.
I'm glad you guys have fun.
I really, I'm really happy you guys have fun about it.
Let me just pull up a tab so we can do our giveaway stuff.
Yeah, the music stopped because I'm trying to sell the
giveaway and stuff for it.
Let's listen to the song first before I set it up because I
want to I'm glad I find this community because it's fun.
I'm glad you have fun.
I'm glad you guys are having fun I'm glad you enjoyed it
with Ashi Um, yeah, Bordeaux.
Oh my god.
I'm a sub so I never leave unless I get a mod and I love it
here Yeah, our mods love it here.
They are there.
It's not Stockholm syndrome.
They all they are all willingly Will and will and will and
consensual mods right you guys love it here Holy shit, this
is a long-ass credit, see.
I bet the mods are underpaid.
Idiot, they're not even paid.
They do it for free.
And they paid me.
And the mods paid me.
And the...
Look, here.
You see, they're super coming.
We're hostages anyway, so we couldn't leave if we wanted to.
we can pay doki for mine you can never quit you can never
paul's almost quit paul's like uh willingly let his mod get
stolen only for i don't remember who it was only for alex to
give him mod back we wanted to like she's gonna eat us like
she ate the lady yeah don't make me oh shit what's this why
the fuck wait what where am i oh thank you for playing i
thought i thought this was i thought i can move again that's
why didn't that happen to mark with lauren when he wanted to
um then he would be in the end here i took so and i ordered
food and went to pick it up and it finished when he got back
oh my god do we go back no okay we're gonna do our little
giveaway so if you guys don't know every time we hit um
eight every time we get like eight subs we uh do a little
sketch giveaway for ourselves so basically um um azer just
met dm me azer dm me because i'm gonna forget to so you
should dm me about so every time we hit eight uh we get
eight subs we do a little sketch giveaway where i um let uh
do a little giveaway for my selves where they can redeem a
where they can win a little sketch for me um so yeah let me
let me fucking pull this up for you guys because i keep
forgetting to do it okay uh all right okay
oh my god what the fuck jericho oh my god Jericho!
Holy shit!
Thank you!
Whoa!
Can we get some Park Nights real quick?
For Jericho, for the fucking seven gifted subs!
Holy shit!
Okay, so we're gonna pull up two winners now.
We're gonna pull up two winners.
Thank you so much!
Jericho, thank you, thank you guys.
I really do appreciate the one before we were allowed to
enter again because I won last stream, I think.
Yeah, yeah, if you guys win before, You're not eligible for
the giveaway, so, because I want, like, everyone who has not
yet won the sketch to have a chance to win it.
So, but you guys can enter it just to see if you'll get
picked, but I did finish it, God, and I just finished it.
We just finished watching the credits and everything, so I'm
just going to, I'm going to fucking pull up the giveaway tab
real quick, guys.
So, let me, let me fucking pull it up for you guys.
all right where the fuck where is it giveaway there we go
all right all right so you guys see here i'm just gonna so
so the the i need to fucking do all this
i need to fucking remember how to do this so you see it the
keyword is exclamation point enter exclamation point enter
to enter the giveaway and the only rules is that um all you
uh you just have to dm me on discord if you get picked we're
picking two winners is dm me on discord and um it can it's
only a chibi sketch and it can't have there's no no
overcomplicated designs or armor because i can't i can't
deal with that i i'm too dumb for that please don't yes
titties i'll draw i'll draw big bobsers if you want but just
no armor and over complicated designs i i i'm not strong
enough guys i'm not strong enough for that so let me okay
i'm gonna do a countdown 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 victory 81 so
i'm gonna roll again against victory 81 or is i'm trying to
roll until um who hasn't won yet gets it.
I remember I've done a sketch for Victor, so we're gonna do
another re-roll.
We're gonna do another re-roll.
Mushikai, congratulations!
Congratulations!
Just DM me on this grade of what you want for your sketch.
And when was this not rigged?
Mushikai got it.
They have not got the sketch before.
So it wasn't as rigged.
Okay, one more, one more roll, one more roll.
uh jay thank you congratulations congratulations
whoo all right it's not rigged today guys it wasn't rigged
today just DM me on the screen guys the winners the two
winners thank you again thank you again everyone uh thank
you i really do really do appreciate the all those love and
support today you guys are amazing you guys are amazing i'm
really do appreciate it not totally rigged today was not a
rigged day today was not a rig day think that's crazy i just
consumed caught and spit today all right so thank you
everyone for coming to the stream i really appreciate we had
a fun time i honestly i had a lot of fun today and i really
appreciate all you guys hanging out with me and looking uh
uh keeping becoming as we try as we finish this game in 30
minutes it's crazy i know it's sad that the stream was only
30 minutes but hey like damn i'm sorry that this was only a
30 minute stream guys such a short stream um what is the
discord case i want to do exclamation point discord uh uh
for and i'm just too good at this game yeah i was insane i
was looking speed running this i was buddy hopping and
everything guys i yeah guys thank you everyone for the
follows for the race today for the love and support i really
appreciate it i'll see you guys tomorrow for a massage
anyway um yeah bye guys